to your people you are divergent to me
you are a miracle you're genetically
pure come to me we're going to we're
going to turn everybody in it just like
you and we're going to save the world
they make them to brave that leads to
being cruel they make them to peaceful
then they become passive nothing to
worry about you're safe now hi welcome
to the barracks this is where the Bureau
members live this set is huge it's huge
my first if Shin your first was in here
my character Matthew has a little tour I
think starts from over there welcome
your arrival is the most exciting events
some of us have ever known and it was
kind of a nerve-wracking experience
because not only was it my first working
day but I also had like a page and a
half over monologue and I had 500 x just
looking at me Tobias Eaton you've been
assigned to me it's a lot of firepower
I remember when I much I mean the first
day she like walked towards me and just
hugging me right away i'm too light
school the first day sit with the cool
kids at the same table so there were
people just genetically altering you but
altering you those who want people to be
who they are they're the heroes of us
not the people trying to change you to
be like me